I say if I say that lady is the way the
men will and if she's right there if I
say You're fat the way the men will
process it is they'll look and they'll
say is she fat and the way the women
will process it is it's how you say it
don't say it like that in your tone now
why do I think this is a feminine thing
why don't men do this too and yes they
do but typically it's for women so now
when you go into a guy's locker rooms
now I've never been in a guy's locker
room but there's a reason we have
phrases like locker room talk because I
think if women heard the way that men
talk in a locker room a lot of us would
go home crying we can't take it we're
not meant to communicate like that but
when you go into a woman's locker room
now it might be different than how we
talk in public but I mean there's a
reason women will call each other fake
instead of saying things to their faces
so what does that say this is a feminine
imperative this is a feminine point of
view and the problem with men nowadays
is they've been taught to always think
about the woman's point of view they're